Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Schon was vor, lass doch mal Domino spielen.
Verboten.
Oder Fallschirmspringen.
Hüttenkäse essen.
Abends oder morgens auch verboten.
Buch, Netzpolitik Nummer vierhundertunddrei vom, was haben wir denn heute eigentlich? Den sechzehnten August zwanzig einundzwanzig. Es ist ein
Montag, wir verraten es euch und wir machen jetzt schon die Wochenendplanung. Und stellt sich raus, egal, was man machen will, alles verboten.
Und zwar ist Domino spielen am Sonntag verboten in Alabama. Fallschirmspringen in Florida oder auch in Florida, wenn auch nur in Tampa Bay.
Achtzehn Uhr keinen Hüttenkäse verzehren. Hat das Internet gesagt.
Immer sonntags, ne? Sind wir immer so ein.
Ja, immer sonntags, hat das Internet gesagt.
Schon. Ja, aber wir haben halt nur Sonntag Zeit und das ist halt genau unsere Reiseroute.
Genau.
Ja? Scheiße.
Aber bevor ihr jetzt wieder mit irgendwelchen Kommentaren kommt, dass das ja alles ganz anders ist. Wir haben das recherchiert. Wir haben mindestens zwei Minuten lang im Internet gesucht und die erstbeste Seite genommen, die das behauptet hat und.
Was soll man noch mehr tun? Also ja, so viel Zeit haben wir jetzt auch nicht.
Das ist aber schon äh finde ich ein Recherchestandard, der zumindest für ein Introvolumen von der Politik ausreichen sollte. Kleiner Spoiler, für den Rest haben wir uns ein bisschen mehr Mühe gegeben.
Ja, wobei jetzt, man muss auch sagen, so mit dem, was, was verboten ist und was nicht, da kennen wir uns einfach nicht so aus. Selche, das ist nicht so unsere äh unsere Primärkompetenz, die auseinandersetzung mit Verboten.
Wir sind nämlich mehr so zweihunderter Typen. Ja, wir dürfen alles, aber äh
Wir haben's ja schon angedeutet, wir wollen ja uns ja auch ein wenig dem HTTP Status qoot äh holen und heute ist halt vierhundertdrei ran und vierhundertdrei, wer das schon geahnt haben, heißt schlicht und ergreifend vor Bitten,
und ist halt eigentlich hätte man ihn auch verboten nennen können, weil es ja das Wort ja so populär ist auch im englischen Sprachraum.
Das ist.
Verboten.
Ja, da da kocht das Blut. Ich finde verboten ist die Steigerung von vor Binnen. Verbinden ist eine so.
Ja, ich habe also ich muss auch tatsächlich sagen, ich habe ähm.
Ja, also ich habe gerade äh glaube ich, du erinnerst mich daran, dass ich, glaube ich, gestern in einem Code, da hätte ich ein vier null drei setzen müssen, habe ich aber nicht. Also ist auch für uns äh sehr, sehr lehrreich hier
Und äh da haben wir auch Feedback zu bekommen, nämlich von Andre. Und das ist auch das äh war mir nicht so bekannt,
Zu den dreistelligen Ziffernfolgen habe ich einen historischen Hintergrund, weil ich mal aus Spaß die frühen RFCs durchgestöbert habe. FCs sind die, die de facto Internet-Standards, ja? Das Prinzip
wurde zuerst bei FDP eingeführt, also dem Fall Transfer Protokoll, wo nebenbei Mail.
Ja,
nebenbei Mail zuerst eingeführt wurde. Wenn ich das grade spontan richtig gefunden habe in RFC sechs vierzig, die Notation war das ein eins XX, ein tendenziellen positiven aber unfertigen Zustand meldet,
zwei XX positiv und fertig. Drei ist nicht schlecht, aber auch nicht fertig, wie zum Beispiel die frage da drüben mein Nachricht Redirection.
Vier was Negatives, was auch wieder weggehen kann. Also vier null vier könnte sich auflösen, wenn die Datei dann doch noch auftaucht, vier null zwei könnte durch Bezahlung zu zweihundert werden. Und fünf permanente Fehler,
Das passt mit fünfhundert,
ähm dem Server ist grad übel oder er macht Kur in natürlich nicht mehr wirklich, aber als jedenfalls hatte DDP entwickelt wurde, war FDP schon gut gereift.
Gut gereift.
Der war der war.
Das stimmt. Damals war das gut gereift, inzwischen macht's dann etwas überreifen Eindruck. Ähm,
Und das Konzept der Response Codes auch mit SMTP durchgesetzt, da war es nicht schwer, die Notation leicht angepasst zu übernehmen. Und so kommt es, dass man die Response Codes eine Reihe von Internetprotokollen sehr ähnlich aufgebaut findet. Ja, super.
Danke Andre. Tatsächlich wird man mit den anderen Codes natürlich nicht so oft konfrontiert, weil äh.
Ja, warum eigentlich? Weil man diese,
Protokolle eher dran äh nicht nicht direkt sieht oder nicht die Fehlermeldungen direkt bekommt, äh einfach nur, wer jemals versucht hat, ein Mählkleid einzurichten, weiß, dass da die in der steht, funktioniert nicht. Nicht wieso. Ähm.
Aber sehr schön.
Das kam überhaupt erst dadurch, dass eigentlich die Webbrowser äh und das ja auch heute eigentlich noch relativ lazy dabei sind, weil sie eigentlich diese Fehlermeldung dann,
nicht unbedingt immer selber aufgelöst haben oder nicht nicht unbedingt immer wussten was zu tun ist, ja, beziehungsweise bei diesem,
Einser ist ja sozusagen ja,
ist ja tendenziell positiv, da passiert ja überall noch was, nur bei vier ist halt irgendwie so dieser klassische Fehler und manches wurde dann auch erstmal einfach nur so angezeigt, deswegen ist grad vier null vier so populär geworden, weil's halt.
Oft kam,
Ja und die Fünfhunderter, die kommen nicht so oft, aber die hat man sicherlich auch schon mal gesehen, wenn dann wieder irgend so ein Jaba-Code einem so sein sein inneres Magengeschwür auf dem Bild schon malt, dann äh dann ist so ein Fünfhunderter-Zustand erreicht.
Ja oder äh Datenbankverbindung, Schlickfeder oder so, ne. Denn insgesamt, glaube ich, kann man sagen, in HTTP werden die.
Äh weißt du, wenn du mit HTTP Statusmeldungen umgehst, als Mensch ist es eigentlich.
Relativ egal, ja? Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie zwischen zwei mit einer API sprichst oder so, dann sagst du natürlich auch häufig einfach nur guck mal, ob der Staat es Q zweihundert ist, ansonsten ähm.
Ist sowas anders.
Ist irgendwas anders, ja? Also deswegen kann man sich auch vorstellen, warum die eben nicht so.
Nicht so dogmatisch umgesetzt werden. Das als Entschuldigung, weil mir gerade einfällt, dass ich eben in in einem Stück Code, was ich gestern geschrieben habe, das auch nicht korrekt gemacht habe.
So Georg, äh kommentiert, ach herrje, die HTP-Status kurz lesensicher, wie das Drehbuch zum LNP French heißt und es ist es wird wirklich spannend in ein paar Wochen. Vier null neun.
Konflikt.
Nach der Bundestagswahl gibt es einen epischen Streit darüber welche Partei mit der jeweiligen Partei Connect App am meisten Wählerdaten verloren hat. Linus beharrt darauf, dass die CDU in diesem Fall den besten Job gemacht hat
Mit Hilfe der sogenannten Leeken Migration hat eine der anderen Parteien dies ausgenutzt,
die Kräfteverhältnisse verschoben. Tim glaubt eher, dass es die SPD war, die am meisten Daten verloren hat und dass es eine Zählweise liege? Die Positionen sind unvereinbar, die Folge endet mit Smoke on the water.
Eine Ankündigung eines LNP Fox durch Linus.
Vier null zehn, Gon, Tim moderiert die Sendung alleine und lässt einen aus den Audioaufnahmen der Vergangenheit angelernten deep fake, Audio Avatar von Linus zu Wort kommen. Das wird allerdings erst im Produkt der LNP vierhundertelf verraten. Einige Hörer mutmaßen in den Kommentaren zur Sendung bereits das Linus irgendwie anders rübergekommen sei
auf Fragen ernsthaft
ach komm, lass uns das mit Blockchains machen und Backups sind für Anfänger geantwortet hat. Tim stellt im Nachhinein fest, dass er beim Training für das ML Modell, für den minus Audio Avatar das Fleck,
Bindestrich nicht mitgesetzt hatte.
Ich glaube, Mindes Irony, oder? Mindest, also ohne Irony, oder? Mit Irony, keine Ahnung.
Vier null eins. Der echte Linus ist zurück, Klammer auf yay, hat in der Zwischenzeit einige Folgen vom
Zugfunk-Podcast gehört und nimmt sich an deren
mittlerer Dauer von mehreren Stunden. Ein Beispiel, sei neu, auch Ironiefähiger, Audia Avatar aus LMP vierhundertzehn, übernimmt inzwischen Standardberatungsdienste und entlastet damit das Original.
Vierhundertdreizehn nach höherer Beschwerden a la, ich komme nicht mehr zum arbeiten, weil die LMP vorhin jetzt auf fünf Stunden dauert, wird Besserung gelobt.
Tim und Linus schlürfen in der Weihnachtsfolge eine Stunde lang nur Heißgetränk.
Sehr schön. Ist vierhundertachtzehn schon Weihnachten.
Wenn wir so ähm also wenn wir unsere Frequenz weiter so niedrig halten, dann vielleicht auch vorbei.
Das ist sehe ich noch nicht so ganz, aber es könnte so der Glühwein im im Frühherbst sein.
So, dann hatten wir ein bisschen gesprochen in der letzten Sendung über.
Da antwortet MSPherre hat bisher ja so gut funktioniert, weil im Prinzip alles vorbei war, bevor das
Opfer überhaupt den Angriff bemerkt. Halte ich bei Dogsing oder Erpressung in Verbindung mit denen in Deutschland üblichen Uploadraten verdeutlich
unwahrscheinlicher. Also er nimmt darauf Bezug, dass die inzwischen ja mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten.
Drohen
und ich habe das interpretiert als, sage ich mal, den Siegeszug des Backups, das äh sich eben die sagen so, hm, nicht, dass die nachher doch auf die Idee kommen, nicht zu zahlen, weil sie einen weil sie einen Backup haben. Deswegen
drohen wir außerdem noch mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten. Und natürlich diese Daten müssen erst exfiltriert werden und das ist ähm.
Dass es ein langwieriger Zeitraum oder ein langwieriger Prozess bei niedrigen Datenraten? Oft hast du aber bei diesen Erpressungsdingern, wo also mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten gedroht wird,
ähm bestimmte Unternehmen betroffen, die ähm vielleicht auch bessere Anbindungen haben und nicht irgendwie mit Consumer oder ähm Mittelstands DSL äh Verbindung arbeiten.
Muss man natürlich auch sagen.
So ein heute üblicher Angriff auf eine Organisation, der geht dann doch durchaus mit einer längeren Zeit einher. Die vergeht zwischen der initialen Infektion.
Und dem tatsächlichen Zugriff durch die. Hauptsächlich liegt das daran, ähm dass sie nicht mehr alle Hecken, die sie initial infizieren,
sondern sich nur bei einigen halt die Mühe machen, ne, die das Active Directory zu kompromittieren und dann hast du natürlich auch äh Zeit, vielleicht äh langsam.
Oder auch über längere Zeit ein paar Daten zu zu exfiltrieren, ja? Also insofern das ist natürlich schon richtig, dass uns.
Niedrige Datenübertragungsraten eben auch davor schützen, dass viele Daten in kurzer Zeit äh übertragen werden, aber da diese Gangs äh,
beschäftigt genug sind
potenziell auch äh auch Zeit. Also da würde ich mich jetzt nicht äh also niedrige niedrige Bandbreiten sollten wir jetzt nicht als Sicherheitsfeature bewerben, wenn das die CDU hört, ja, dann,
für ein sicheres deutsches Netz. Bandbreiten Limit auf der Datenautobahn,
damit hier damit der Hacker, die die Daten nicht wegnehmt. Ihr denkt, ist auch gut für dich.
Na toll.
Aber äh eine schöne äh eine schöne äh Ironie, die ich dann, die mir nicht entgangen ist natürlich.
Dann hatten wir über die CDU Connect App äh gesprochen, da haben natürlich sich auch sehr viele zu Wort gemeldet. Er sagte, ACY zur CDU-App, ich vermisse eine Diskussion über das Thema Datenschutz.
Haben denn alle Bürgerinnen, deren politische Einstellung dort protokolliert wurden, der Datenspeicherung zugestimmt. Ähm Achtung, ich bin kein Anwalt, aber ich interpretiere die Situation folgendermaßen.
Natürlich haben die Leute dem nicht zugestimmt und wahrscheinlich mussten sie es auch nicht.
Weil ja ein großer Teil der Leute eben dort auch nicht namentlich erfasst wurde. Jetzt gibt es also weil die App das nicht vorgesehen hat, die hatte nur ein Kommentarfeld und da haben dann die Nutzerinnen gerne mal die Daten den den,
Namen eingetragen, ne, irgendwie so heißt der Wilfried aus dem aus dem Schützenverein, der war schon zweimal König, den kenne ich und die Frau, die Gertrud, die war ja auch schon hier. Dieser Naturengruppe mit der Gerda,
so dass äh hast du dann irgendwie. Äh das ist dann natürlich ein DSGVO äh Verstoß vermutlich.
Allerdings glaube ich, muss man dann auch so ein bisschen sagen, ja, das ist ähm.
Nicht strukturiert erfasst.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass man da jetzt ernsthaft dann, also dann müsstest du nämlich den Leuten zuleibe rücken, die diese CDU-Connect-App genutzt haben. Also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob da wirklich was äh.
Schiefgeht.
Oder ob das, ob das irgendwie juristisch wirklich Aussicht hat. Zumal die Daten hier hat ja auch eh irgendwie keiner ähm diese, dass die irgendwo veröffentlicht wurden, erscheint mir ja auch eher nicht so, sonst hätte ich die Daten ja inzwischen.
Äh gesehen irgendwo. So und ähm dann haben wir äh ja als CCC entschieden, wir werden Schwachstellen nicht mehr der CDU melden und ähm das
sondern auf den traditionellen Wegen machen und da gibt's einen schönen Blog also eine schöne Mail auf der Liste. Das ist eine sehr alte,
Mailing-Liste, die äh ja, Full discloseer heißt, in der ähm vollständige ähm,
Schwachstellen direkt geschildert werden und zwar an erster Stelle dort und niemand anders
ja? Also im Gegensatz zu der responsible Disclosure, äh wo man vorher Bescheid sagt und sagte übrigens, hier in dem, also wenn ihr es gefixt habt, veröffentliche ich es oder jetzt in dieser sehr äh,
und sehr klug abgewandelten Form. Wir veröffentlichen in so und so vielen Monaten, egal ob ihr ob ihr es gefixt habt oder nicht. Ähm,
wacht man bei der, schreibt halt alles sofort dahin.
Und äh ja, dampft einfach dieses Wissenswissen im Netz und gibt den äh Verantwortlichen keinen Vorsprung zur Behebung.
Ja und da gibt's eine in der CDU in der Version drei Punkt acht von Team Smack Back, die eine sehr peinliche,
Cross Side Scripting im Registrierungsform haben, also du kannst quasi,
ähm in den als Name sagen, du heißt wie ein Java Skript äh im Frontend und dann wird das äh potenziell im Back-End.
Ausgeführt. Die das Team schreibt dazu,
üblicherweise wollten wir diese Schwachstelle als äh machen, aber wir waren abgeschreckt von den von den ähm Vorkommnissen, die äh hier bei der,
Widmann stattgefunden haben und deswegen haben wir hier einen anderen Weg gewählt und diese Schwachstelle in einem,
Aktuellen Produkt eben hier als und dann hat noch,
Twitterer, auch in im Prinzip eine äh gemacht und hat gesagt.
Ähm ey hier übrigens CDU ähm.
Fix doch mal bitte euren Mailserver, da ist noch die Schwachstelle drauf. Der Mailserver läuft unter.
OWA zwanzig zehn Punkt CDU DE. OWA steht für Outlook Web Exces und ich muss sagen, wenn ich mir die anschaue.
Ohne wie das jetzt genauer anzuschauen, sieht das wirklich aus wie ein relativ alter Outlook Web Access Login, die sehen seit vielen Jahren
echt anders aus, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Äh insofern scheint da wahrscheinlich auch der Domainname Programm zu sein und ähm der Twitter-Nutzer.
Verdächtigt dort, dass es dort noch den, die gibt, also diese Schwachstelle, die seit einigen Monaten sehr problematisch ist.
Oder vor einigen Monaten problematisch war, jetzt einfach nur noch für komplett.
Also nur noch in in den, in den dunkelsten Ecken der Verwesung, findet man die noch, also keine Ahnung, so um die zehntausend Server in Deutschland vielleicht, ja?
Ja, fand ich sehr lustig, hat hat also stattgefunden, wurden halt nicht mehr an die CDU gemeldet, sondern direkt veröffentlicht. So ist das manchmal.
Tja, Pech gehabt.
Ne? Haben wir ja gesagt, wir lehnen dafür die Verantwortung vorsorglich ab. Äh aber sowas kommt eben von sowas.
Dann vielleicht noch ein kleine zwei ein kleines äh Adendom. Wir hatten über die,
Impfzertifikate gesprochen, die nicht mehr ausstellbar waren von den Apotheken
weil es die Schwachstelle gab, dass jeder behaupten konnte, er oder sie hätte eine Apotheke und dann eben auch in die Lage versetzt wurde, ein ähm,
Also Zertifikate auszustellen, mit den Servern. Die Schwachstelle haben sie gefixt und äh ich entnehme
also der Berichterstattung entnehme ich das jetzt die Anbindung mit Hilfe der Hardware der Telematik Infrastruktur erfolgt. Also das, was Martin auch in den Kommentaren zur vorletzten Sendung, die ich in der letzten Sendung
vor äh besprochen habe auch kommentiert hatte. So interpretiere ich diesen Artikel. Zusammen hätten Experten von IBM, der Gematik und des deutschen Apothekerverbands, die,
Bei der Ausstellung der QR-Codes dann auch identifiziert und beseitigt, weil das System lief dann erstmal nicht und hatte Performanceprobleme, nach denen sie's wieder
in den, in den Gängen hatten. Aber, okay, diese Schwachstelle wurde also jetzt beseitigt, ähm, so wie ich das lese, mussten dann die Apotheken sich neu anmelden.
Und äh über die Telematik identifizieren. Und das war ja auch das, was der äh Martin, wie gesagt, vorgeschlagen hat.
Genau, weil.
Und das wussten wir ja am Anfang noch gar nicht, diese Apotheken tatsächlich daran schon teilgenommen haben und sie eigentlich auch nur Zertifikate ausstellen dürfen, wenn sie diese äh Infrastruktur haben, nur benutzen mussten sie es nicht. Also es ist schon.
Ja haben sie denn auch hier die vorgeschriebene Sicherheitstechnik? Ja, die steht dahinten in der Ecke. Ja super, alles klar, weiter.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Impfausweis auf Veranstaltungen zeigen und dann scrollen irgendwie irgendwelche Leute am Eingang da so kurz und drin rum und sagen, ja ist okay,
Ich so, ja, müsst ihr doch, müsst ihr doch scannen. Ja, da haben wir nicht das Gerät für.
Das Gerät ist in der Tasche heißt Smartphone und du baust die aber was willst du machen?
Ja, was willst du machen? Ja, man kann denen dann halt auch einfach nur sagen so, ja, ich meine, ist ja auch deutlich zeitaufwendiger und fehleranfälliger, aber na ja Gott, egal.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Na ja, also auf jeden Fall äh äh läuft es immerhin wieder, es gibt da allerdings auch so einige andere Sachen. Ich habe auch gehört, dass Leute jetzt irgendwie abgelehnt werden, wenn sie bei einer Apotheke versuchen, ihren Impf äh Ausweis sich äh zu holen, der.
Und die Apotheke ist dann nicht in dem, in der Region, wo sie geimpft wurden.
Sie auch nicht verstehe, also ich meine, entweder sind sie in der Lage, das zu verifizieren oder ist in der Lage, das nicht zu verifizieren, aber sieht das jetzt eine räumliche Nähe da in irgendeiner Form hilfreich sein soll.
Na ja, das also ich vermute, dass das ein naiver Versuch ist, ähm.
Missbrauch zu verhindern?
Diese Telegram-Gruppen da, ähm denen entgegen zu treten.
Ja, das äh das stimmt jetzt, wo du's sagst, ähm tja, macht's natürlich für Reisende dann auch nicht unbedingt einfacher, aber hm.
Und vermutlich also der sinnvolle Check wäre eigentlich, du du wohnst in der Region, wo du auch in die Apotheke gehst.
Aber du behauptest jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, in einem anderen Bundesland geimpft zu sein worden zu sein. Was eben unwahrscheinlich oder äh Erklärungs.
Ähm bedürftig wäre.
Ja, wenn auch mittlerweile möglich und ja,
aber dann solltest du halt beim Impfzentrum zumindest, aber nicht beim Arzt. Ähm genau, den Nachweis ja auch schon direkt also es ist, ja, man hätte sich über die Sachen schon vorher Gedanken äh machen müssen und jetzt durch solche Maßnahmen versucht, diesen
ähm potentiellen Betrug zu verhindern.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt ähm.
Ja, also der, der, der, der Betrug findet nur statt, weil du diese Checks machst. Und sonst würde sich kein wird's auch keiner fälschen. Also da, das,
Ja, äh,
du kennst meine Meinung dazu, dass ich das auch nicht gut finde, diese Dinger zu kontrollieren und dass ich diese äh dass ich das nicht nicht schön finde. Wobei man natürlich gleichzeitig auch sagen muss, ähm.
So leichte Schläge auf den Hinterkopf erhöhen das Denkvermögen.
Und wenn man mit diesen Impfausweisen eben die Impfverweigerer ein bisschen piesacken kann, dann wird man daraus unter Umständen halt zumindest insofern die Sprache vom Weizen trennen, dass man,
Verweigerer von den Impfverpeilern trennt und die im Verpeiler halt beim dritten Mal sagen, boah ey,
na ja, jetzt reicht's aber, Telegramm ist gefälschter Impfausweis, kostet ein Huni
Impfzentrum gehen oder zum Hausarzt gehen kostet nüscht. Dann haste bis halt eben also für halbwegs normal denkende Verteiler ist es dann immer noch ein ähm sage ich mal ökonomisch, der steht, steht die Impfung im Vorteil.
Genau, genau da sehe ich den äh Vorteil und wir sehen das ja jetzt auch, auch wenn's.
Eine Bratwurst.
Bratwurst oder äh Zugang zum Stadion, also
gibt durchaus gibt durchaus Incentives, die man da jetzt hochhalten kann und ich glaube, das wird dann eben auch die faulen von den äh wirklich chronischen Leugnern und Verweigerern
trennen und dann wird sich ja zeigen, wie die Prozentsitze wirklich sind. Aber wenn man sich so die aktuellen Impfzahlen anschaut, äh ist da auf jeden Fall der ein oder andere Schlag auf den Hinterkopf erforderlich.
Das könnte er schon sein, ne. Na ja, also
Es ist äh ein ein, ein, ein schwieriges äh Feld. Genauso wie der Bereich, über die wir jetzt äh sprechen,
Ist eigentlich so ein bisschen der Klassiker der schwierigen Felder.
Ne, gerade wenn's um Privatsphäre, Sicherheit und äh Überwachungsmaßnahmen geht.
Nämlich der Bereich des dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs. Was.
Ich muss mich korrigieren, sorry. Es tut mir leid, dich unterbrochen zu haben, aber ich muss mich korrigieren.
Ähm leichte Schläge auf den Hinterkopf erhöhen, nicht das Denkvermögen. Haben Forscher untersucht. Sorry.
Weil.
Sei es das Gegenteil der Fall. Gehirnerschütterung und Risse im Gehirn können entstehen. Ja, also sorry, habe ich äh bevor jetzt die die Korrekturen kommen, tut mir leid. Ja, es stimmt gar nicht.
Oh Gott.
Sorry, ja nicht, das ist doch irgendwie Ärger gibt, ja.
Ja, nachdem du jetzt meine meine vorsichtigen äh Versuch, hier wirklich einen gepflegten Übergang zum von einem schwierigen Thema zu einem schwierigen Thema äh torpediert hast und das äh du aber versuchen, das einzuleiten.
Die Situation,
in netzpolitischen Debatten dreht sich sehr häufig um das Thema des dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs. Ähm das sicherlich ein sehr ernstes und großes,
Problem ist, dass fast so groß ist wie der tatsächliche Kindesmissbrauch über den äh ja hier Beweismittel.
Verteilt werden von Menschen.
Und das ist natürlich ähm illegal in so gut wie jedem Land dieser Erde und ähm gesellschaftlich geächtet, aus gutem Grund und wird ähm,
strafverfolgt, ja? Wir haben ja auch immer wieder, darf man ja nicht vergessen, durch gute Polizeiarbeit dann so Ermittlungserfolge wie
denke vor einem Jahr ungefähr war das länger herein in Münster ähm wo es da diesen Missbrauchsring gab und diese Menschen nutzen.
Natürlich auch ähm.
Technologien der Verschlüsselung und des anonymen Datenaustausches, um dieses Material,
in Umlauf zu bringen. Immer mal wieder gibt es offenbar auch Leute, die da dann damit tatsächlich Geld verdienen und.
Allerdings, was man so hört, scheinen das auch eher äh viel einfach ja Tauschbörsen zu sein, wo Menschen diese Materialien eben anonym miteinander.
Teilen. Wie gesagt, das Problem ist fast so groß wie der tatsächliche Kindesmissbrauch, der da stattfindet. Und ähm natürlich ist es verständlich.
Dass man dagegen vorgehen möchte als Gesellschaft. Ähm der Weg, der gewählt wird,
Ist aber häufig so die Idee der Unmöglichmachung, ja? Ähm in Deutschland die prominenteste Ansatz war das mit den Stoppschildern, Ursula von der Leyen, die also ein sehr untaugliches und verfahren.
Umsetzen wollte, dass also DNS-Server so etwas nicht mehr auflösen. Die einzige Folge davon wäre gewesen, dass eben die äh die Seiten sich nicht mehr auf DNS konzentrieren, sondern zum Beispiel als Hidden Services angeboten werden.
Und äh eine ganze Reihe Overblocking stattgefunden hätte. Und durch diese ähm da gab es dann eben diesen Aufruf löschen statt Sperren und vor allem auch die Forderung.
Führt das einer Strafverfolgung zu, wenn Menschen diese Materialien anbieten, besitzen äh oder teilen oder und äh ja,
oder dafür bezahlen oder was auch immer, die juristischen Formulierungen sind. So, jetzt hat es sich ergeben, dass fast alle großen Tech-Anbieter.
In den USA solchen solche Materialien,
melden und zwar an das. Das ist das National Center von Missing and Explorted Children. Also das nationale Zentrum für äh Vermisste oder ähm.
Äh missbrauchte Kinder oder ausgenutzte Kinder. So und die Unternehmen ähm,
die großen Unternehmen wie jetzt Facebook oder Google, ähm die melden dort die Fälle hin, die ihnen ähm.
Bekannt werden. So, jetzt hat Facebook.
Wie wie werden die ihnen bekannt? Die haben automatische Scanner dafür. Das ist dieses Verfahren Foto-ID von Microsoft. Das haben wir hier auch schon mal in einer Sendung früher genauer erklärt. Das.
Basiert im grob gesagt darauf, dass das Bild in.
In ähm schwarz und weiß, quasi ganz hoher Kontrast gezogen wird und dann in Vierecke aufgeteilt wird und diese Vierecke,
Also quasi das Bild nach und nach symblifiziert wird und darüber am Ende dann einen Fingerabdruck errechnet wird, der mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit gegen.
Minimale kleinere Veränderungen des Bildes resistent ist. Ja, also zum Beispiel wenn du jetzt,
einen Farbstich reinmachst, ist ja jeder Pixel des Bildes anders, aber dadurch, dass du den Kontrast halt wieder äh krass ziehst,
lässt du lässt sich quasi wieder technisch das Bild auf seine wesentlichen Komponenten reduzieren und dafür haben die eben so einen Fingerabdruckverfahren entwickelt. Ähm was da bei solchen Scans zum Einsatz kommt.
Und ähm wenn man sich die Meldungszahlen anschaut, hat Facebook zwanzig Komma drei Millionen Fälle an die Neckmac gemeldet im vergangenen Jahr, glaube ich,
Google fünfhundertsechsundvierzigtausend. Der Unterschied ist mir auch noch nicht ganz klar und Apple hat zweihundertfünfundsechzig Fälle gemeldet. So, jetzt müssen wir natürlich fragen,
so natürlich werden auf Facebook vermutlich sehr viel mehr Bilder getauscht als bei.
Apple, aber Apple hat eben die Fotolibraries der Menschen, ja? Ähm und Google, da würde ich jetzt vermuten, dass Google ähm die haben ja kein soziales Netzwerk mehr, da kann es wahrscheinlich
Google Mail betreffen und vielleicht auch tatsächlich das, was die Google Suche ähm findet.
Ähm Apple hat aber hier natürlich sehr viel sehr viel weniger Nullen hinter der Meldungszahl und es scheint, dass sie da äh für schlecht dastehen.
Ähm und jetzt haben sie angekündigt, dass sie diese Suche.
Vornehmen möchten. So soll's aber eine Sache sagen, diese ganzen Scan-Verfahren funktionieren natürlich nur bei unverschlüsselten Daten,
Wenn ich also jetzt so,
Bild hätte und das unverschlüsselt in, was ich in lege oder so, dann wird das nicht lange dauern, bis das verschwindet und ich potenziell eben äh der Strafverfolgung äh zugeführt werde.
Wenn ich das verschlüssele und irgendwo hinlege, gibt es keine Möglichkeit, dass das zu detektieren. Und glücklicherweise gibt es ja den.
Tendenz dahin, dass wir immer mehr Daten verschlüsseln, weil wir immer mehr Daten äh haben, bauen, austauschen, bereitstellen und ähm,
Das ist ja gut, das ist ja positiv, aber genauso wie das
dann im Falle von Staatstrojanern dazu führt, dass der die eigentliche Scanner auf das System soll und auch bei diesen Sachen der Chatkontrolle, wenn wir mit Patrick Breier darüber gesprochen, wo dann gesagt wird, wir wollen diese Scanner
in euren Messenger bauen, ja, also die E-Privacy
Richtlinien, Ausnahme, die nachher zur Pflicht werden soll, über die wir, glaube ich, auch in der letzten Sendung gesprochen haben
hört man natürlich schon die Nachtigall trapsen und bei Apple ist die Nachtigall jetzt ähm im Betriebssystem ab Herbst.
So die Ankündigung von Apple. Und jetzt können wir uns anhören, wie der Tim sich da schön redet.
Na ja, ich äh will das gar nicht erst mal äh bewerten, sondern erstmal wollte ich mal äh vorstellen, was eigentlich jetzt sozusagen der Plan ist, ne. Also der Grund, warum Apple so wenig Fälle meldet, ist schlicht und ergreifend, dass ihr halt diese Fotos nie gescannt haben,
Und das ist ja schon mal auch äh eins ihrer Argumente äh gewesen, dass sie das halt auch überhaupt nicht tun wollen.
Wollen halt nicht äh die Datenbestände von Nutzern durchforsten. Und das wollen sie halt weder in der Cloud noch,
auf dem Telefon tun. Das ist quasi so der der Kern auch ihrer Ankündigung. Also was haben sie jetzt
gemacht, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, also das ist jetzt quasi der Ausblick
auf eine ganze Reihe von neuen Betriebssystemen, also einmal so ihren ganzen Kladderadatsch von vorne bis hinten durch. IOS für das äh iPhone, iPad, US, fürs iPad, Watch OS für die Uhr
und natürlich macOS für die Max, also alles kommt jetzt im äh Herbst in der neuen Version raus. Eiweiß fünfzehn und äh
Ist acht und wie sie alle heißen. Auf jeden Fall ist es mittlerweile auch so, dass die ganzen
mit einzelnen Varianten eines Kernbetriebssystems mittlerweile so ähnlich sind, dass sie jetzt mehr oder weniger Technologien jetzt auch auf allen Plattformen gleichzeitig releasen können.
Ja und ihre Aussage ist, dass sie halt äh so lange äh da jetzt gar nichts getan haben, weil sie meinten, dass eben die Technologie noch nicht da sei.
Sie das auf die Art und Weise machen können,
wie sie es gerne machen wollen, nämlich unter Beibehaltung der Privatsphäre, das ist so quasi ihre ihre. Ähm.
Auf jeden Fall erstmal auseinander halten sollte, ist.
Was tun Sie eigentlich? Sie haben jetzt irgendwie drei Sachen angekündigt. Die ersten beiden kann man, glaube ich, schnell mal abhaken, die sind äh nicht sonderlich äh umstritten und auch nicht sonderlich umfangreich. Also zunächst einmal.
Sie sprechen hier von Siri und Search, als ob sie irgendwie große Suchdienste am Start hatten, aber man kann ja quasi mit diesem Siri, mit diesem
Apple Alexa äh auch Internetsuchen äh ausführen ja und wenn man das halt benutzt und ähm dann dann äh interpretieren sie halt, wie sie sagen,
entweder so Hilfe suche oder eben so Sesam, Relate Topics, wie sie das nennen, also Cesam ist so jetzt der, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange es diesen Begriff schon gibt, aber das steht eben für Charles, oder sozusagen.
Fotos, ne, äh aller Art, die eben Kindesmissbrauch dokumentieren, also Sesam werde ich jetzt mal hier auch einen weiteren benutzen als ähm Abkürzung dafür.
Und wenn man halt danach äh sucht
dann wird halt irgendwie Hilfe eingeblendet, Ressourcen eingeblendet, hier melde dich doch da und so weiter. Äh beziehungsweise wenn halt Leute jetzt aktiv sich auf auf die Suche nach solchen Material machen
meinen sie halt auch, dass sie dann äh entsprechende Warnungen einblenden und darauf hinweisen, dass das ja alles irgendwie nicht so geil wäre oder nicht so oder verboten oder was auch immer. Also da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau
was da steht, aber das ist sozusagen das Erste. Ähm das Zweite ist, dass sie halt explizit in diese Messages App auf dem,
Eiweiß, also auf dem auf dem iPhone eine Funktion einbauen, die halt ja,
Wie sie das so schön sagen, sensitive Content erkennt. Ja, also sie benutzen quasi ihre Machine Learning, Algorithmen, die ja in der Lage sind, mittlerweile alles Mögliche zu erkennen,
und sind da wohl recht konfident, dass sie halt tja, erkennen können. Das ist halt, sagen wir mal, eine.
Eine eine Antwort auf diese Problematik von so Sexfotos verschicken und soll eine Funktion sein.
Die ähm vor allem Eltern in die Lage äh versetzt, das eben bei Kindern
sozusagen als Warnow einblenden zu lassen, also entweder um Kinder davon abzuhalten, äh selber Nacktfotos zu verschicken oder eine Warnung anzuzeigen, wenn sie welche
empfangen. Ja, also um dieses Problem der der Anbahnung. Ähm irgendwie an äh anzugehen.
Und das Ganze ist halt gekoppelt mit diesem Familysharing. Also das ist jetzt sozusagen keine Funktion, die auf allen Telefonen ist,
sondern dass es eben in dieser Konstellation, wo man äh so verschiedene AppleIDs gruppiert zu einer Familie und dann sind bestimmte eben als Kinder ausgewiesen und da ist ja auch das Alter dabei und die Funktion verhält sich halt ein bisschen anders. Ähm
je nachdem wie alt die Kinder äh sind. Sprich bei Kindern unter zwölf äh ist dann auch eine Benachrichtigung,
der Eltern äh mit dabei und bei älteren,
werden sozusagen die Kinder nur selber gewarnt, das ist auch alles Opt-In, also nicht die folgtmäßig äh eingeschaltet,
und die Funktion ist halt so, dass wenn du jetzt so ein Foto bekommst, wo die der Algorithmus schlägt an und sagt so, ja hier Sensitive Content, dann ist es erstmal blöd und dann wird halt so drauf hingewiesen, so ja, hier könnte problematischer Inhalt sein, willst du das wirklich sehen? Dann kannst du aber immer trotzdem noch dich drüber hinweg setzen und ja sagen.
Bei den kleineren Kindern ist es halt so und dann wird dann auch gesagt so ja okay kannst du dir jetzt angucken, aber wir benachrichtigen dann auf jeden Fall auch deine Eltern,
So, ne? Das ist der der Modus, den sie jetzt hier machen. Dadurch, dass es in dieser Messe App ist, ist es halt keine Funktion von iMessage, sondern es deckt dann quasi auch SMS mit ab
aber eben nicht die anderen Messaging Dienste. Es ist wohl auch im Gespräch.
Diese Funktionalität generell im Betriebssystem auch anzubieten. Ohnehin werden diese ganzen Funktionen als Teil des Betriebssystems äh angeboten und werden nicht über noch einen anderen Seitenkanal äh aktualisiert.
Ähm das wird sich zeigen, ob
ob sich sowas dann äh etablieren, wird das dann andere Messenger sich sozusagen derselben Funktion bedienen, dass sie einfach sagen, ja hier Betriebssystem, ich habe gerade ein
bekommen, sag mal was dazu und dann im Prinzip in der Lage werden ja auch diesen selben Prozess oder vergleichbaren Prozess anzusteuern. Das äh liegt jetzt alles noch ein bisschen.
In der Zukunft. So, das sind so die ersten beiden Maßnahmen, die Sie angekündigt haben. Ähm und die.
Die Maßnahme, die jetzt am meisten Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat, ähm die bezieht sich auf,
i-Cloud-Fotos, i-Cloud Fotos ist ja quasi Apples, Methode, wie ähm Apple-Nutzer,
ihre Fotosammlung, ihre Foto Library,
im iCloud-System hinterlegen können, so dass man das nicht alles auf den die Weiße speichern muss, ich mache ein Foto aufm iPhone und wenn die iCloud Library eingeschaltet ist, dann wird das halt
automatisch in diese Cloud hochgeladen und mit den ganzen anderen
Rechnern, die da äh mit derselben Apple ID arbeiten und wo auch iCloud-Fotos eingeschaltet ist, wird das dann halt gesündt, sodass man halt hier ein Foto macht und es dort sofort verwenden kann.
Und was sie halt machen werden und ähm man muss nochmal darauf hinweisen,
Das ist jetzt eine Funktion, die jetzt erstmal nur in den USA zum Tragen kommt. Das ist jetzt quasi nichts, was jetzt in Deutschland aktiv werden würde, also zumindest nicht jetzt, nicht zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
Ähm das halt, wenn,
Fotos in diese, also wenn i Cloud Fotos eingeschaltet ist und nur dann, dann ähm werden diese Bilder geprüft, ob es sich dabei um bekanntes
Cesar Material,
handelt. Und hier kommt die anfangs erwähnte ähm dieses Anfangs erwähnte Nationalcenter Children, dieses Neckmack oder NCMEC äh mit rein, was halt in den USA
quasi,
die einzige Organisation ist, die solche Bilder überhaupt vorrätig haben darf. Das heißt, deren Datenbank existiert nur dort.
Und wie du schon gesagt hast, gibt verschiedene Methoden, wie man eben,
auf die Identität dieser Fotos prüfen kann, ohne dass die Fotos selber wieder in die Welt geschickt werden,
Ne, also mit entsprechenden Fingerprintmethoden. So wie du das von der Microsoft-Methode beschrieben hast, scheint das hier äh noch ein bisschen anders äh zu laufen.
Ähm ich vermute mal, dass Apple hier äh mit der Organisation das,
technisch gemeinsam, koordiniert hat und hier sprechen sie von sogenannten Noyalas, also ist die ganze Zeit von die Rede, Hashtag ist ja so allgemein so,
so ein bisschen in der in der Debatte so ein ist, du nimmst irgendeine Datei, du bildest einen Hash und dann hast du so
eine ID, die quasi so ein bisschen für die ganze Datei spricht, ohne dass so die ganzen Daten durchackern musst. Und in der Theorie ist es halt so, du änderst irgendwo ein Bit und dann ändert sich auch irgendwo ein Bit in diesem,
das heißt also aus sehr viel mehr Daten wird ein sehr viel kleinerer Zahlenbereich gemacht, der aber trotzdem so ist, dass dass er in der Regel jede Änderung irgendwie,
bekommt und
äh das würde natürlich sofort fehlen, wenn du halt bei irgend so einer Bilddatei auch nur ein Bike weglässt oder äh von Farbe auf schwarz weiß gehst oder das Bild äh abschneidest, anderes,
äh machst oder auch irgendwelche Filter drüber jagst, dann ändern sich ja im Prinzip alle Bits auf einmal und so normaler Hashtag würde dann einfach überhaupt nicht mehr greifen
Und dieser ist halt eher
so diese Methode wie heutzutage mit Machine Learning, auch Bilder generell analysiert werden, ne? Dieses Deep-Learning geht ja mehr auf Features ein und ähm schaut sich quasi die eigentlichen Struktur dieses Bildes an.
Und sie sagen halt, dass eben mit dieser Methode sie eben auch.
Mehrere Varianten eines Fotos ähm auf einen eindeutigen Wert zurückführen können, selbst wenn eben solche Filterkopping und Farbmodifikationen durchgeführt worden sind.
Wie gut das funktioniert, kann ich nicht sagen, aber das ist äh die Behauptung, die hier im Raum ist. Man nennt das dann perceptive äh Hashing, ne.
So und was passiert jetzt?
Du hast also ein neues Bild, ja, was irgendwoher kommt, vom Internet oder äh aus irgendeiner anderen äh Quelle und das soll halt in die iCloud-Foto Libri hochgeladen werden und dann wird eben.
Dieses Bild wird von diesem Bild, dieser neurollas gebildet und das Ganze wird.
Verglichen mit einer Liste von die eben von diesen,
NCMEC kommt. Diese Liste, dieser Bilder der bekannten Bilder, die ist Teil des Betriebssystem Updates, wird mit dem Betriebssystem quasi mit ausgeliefert.
Und das findet dann ein Vergleich statt. Und der Vergleich ähm findet.
Auf eine kryptographische Methode statt. Also man nennt das Private Intersection.
Und in dem Fall äh werden also quasi diese beiden Sets, also auf der einen Seite hier meine Fotos, hier äh die Foto-IDs, diese von der äh Datenbank werden miteinander verglichen.
Und damit soll verhindert werden, dass eben diese Sets komplett zugänglich werden, man aber trotzdem irgendwie diese Inhalte miteinander vergleichen kann.
Eine ähnliche Technik wird wohl schon zum Einsatz gebracht, um zum Beispiel Passwörter im Schlüsselbund mitliegt,
Passwörtern ähm zu vergleichen. Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal besprochen. Äh wie hieß noch gleich diese Passwörterdatenbank? Minus.
Die hören diese Liste. Da schickt man quasi äh einen Teil des aber nur hin, das Ende und kriegt dann alle, die auch so enden und vergleicht dann lokal, ob man diesen hat.
Mhm. Also Apple sagt zumindest, dass sie dieselbe Technik dort äh auch, äh dass sie sie dort auch verwenden.
So und jetzt kommt der eigentliche Punkt. Es gibt dann also quasi in diesem cryptographischen Vergleich gibt es ein Ergebnis,
und das Ergebnis ist dann, würde man sagen, es ist so, ja, ist Bestandteil dieser Datenbank oder nicht, aber ganz so einfach ist es nicht, sondern was sie machen ist, sie erzeugen, sie kriegen sozusagen ein kryptographisches Vergleichsergebnis,
was dem Code selber in dem Moment auf dem Telefon gar nicht sagt, ob das jetzt ja oder nein war.
Sondern sie schließen das in so einen Wauscher ein, also ist so ein kleiner Kryptographischer Anhang, der dann einfach mit dem Bild hochgeladen wird, in die Wolke. Und man kann diesen Wortschal selber erstmal nicht ansehen,
Wie das Ergebnis eigentlich war. Und der Grund, warum man das nicht sehen kann in dem Fall, ist, dass es ein sogenannter.
So ein Schwellwert, Kryptosystem ist, dass diese zusätzliche Absicherung das bedeutet, dass du.
Eine bestimmte Mindestmenge an solchen Vergleichen insgesamt positiv haben muss, bevor du sehen kannst, dass diese Menge positiv
das lässt sich irgendwie einstellen, er bleibt gesagt, es liegt so ungefähr derzeit bei dreißig Bildern. Mit anderen Worten, wenn du ein Bild in deiner
Foto Librier hast, was jetzt mit dieser Datenbank.
Datenbank von positiv verglichen wird, löst das erstmal noch gar nichts aus. Wenn du aber,
dreißig Bilder in deiner Datenbank hast, dann werden die überhaupt erst als solche in der Cloud erkennbar.
Und dann kann ein System erst sagen, so, ah okay, hier ist der Schwellwert überschrieben und dann kann man eben diese Wortschau überhaupt erst auslesen. Und das wiederum.
Triggert dann.
Also sollte das jetzt sozusagen passieren. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie dreißig Bilder mit diesem Schwellwert sozusagen äh erreicht, dann ist Cloud-seitig überhaupt erst der Einblick möglich,
und dann triggert das bei Apple eine manuelle Überprüfung. Das heißt, Apple.
Hat dann irgendwie ein Team, die dann Zugriff auf diesen Benutzer-Account äh bekommen, sich diese fraglichen Bilder anschauen können, ob das sozusagen,
nicht irgendwelche waren, sondern ob das jetzt wirklich problematischer Inhalt äh ist und der Account wird äh auch erstmal gesperrt.
Ja und wenn ein Nutzer der Meinung ist, er wäre zu unrecht äh gesperrt, so dann gibt's auch einen Prozess, äh mit dem man da sich sozusagen entsprechend beklagen kann. Aber diese.
Ähm dieses Schwellwertsystem soll die Chance von Fehlmeldungen reduzieren. Sie sprechen von eins zu einer Billion, sozusagen wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ja, also das ist das ist sozusagen das, was sie äh tun und sie treiben da einen relativ großen Aufwand,
eben dazu führt, dass weder der Code auf dem Telefon eigentlich weiß, was das Ergebnis dieser Untersuchung ist, ja? Noch äh das.
Es ähm irgendwelche Aussagen, aber irgendwelche Bilder äh gibt in der,
nicht erst dieser Schwellwert erreicht ist, also zu sagen erst, wenn sie sich wenn sich, ich sage mal so etwas erdrückender Beweis angesammelt hat, ist der Beweis als solcher überhaupt erst sichtbar und das triggert dann
den manuellen Prozess und wenn der dann halt positiv beschieden wird, so ja OK hier wirklich problematisches Material
dann erfolgt eine Meldung an diese NC MEC Organisation. Ja, also das ist sozusagen das.
Das Modell, was sich jetzt äh Apple hat einfallen lassen, um.
Ja, ob zu sagen, das ist ihre Position so. Wir sehen das als problematisch an.
Dass sowohl Kinder aufgefordert werden, das ist diese Sache mit den Messages, ja? Als auch, dass Leute.
Solche Fotosammlungen anlegen und wenn halt Fotosammlungen eine gewisse Menge annehmen, dann.
Weist es darauf hin, dass es sich um problematischen Account handelt, der sie dann.
Quasi verpflichtet, ähm das zu melden.
Ja, aber das hat ja sehr, sehr lange erzählt, dass sie letztendlich einen Inhaltescanner.
Auf deinem Telefon laufen lassen für ähm Inhalte, was weiß ich, die dir zugesendet werden und die für dich privat sind. Und,
das ist denke ich in dieser Form noch nie da gewesen und
eine Dammbruch, da könnt ihr noch so viel Mühe geben, denn
was ich eingangs natürlich nicht erwähnt habe, ist es sämtliche solcher Maßnahmen, die anfangs mit äh Terrorismus und Kindesmissbrauch begründet werden, ihren,
Weg in die allgemeine Nutzung finden. Um mal ein ein einfaches Beispiel zu nennen, weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist, aber ähm.
Wenn man irgendwie für iTunes, für Apple Music zahlt, dann kann man ja auch eigene MP3s in äh in in dieses iTunes reinwerfen.
Und äh die werden auch über Geräte synchronisiert, ja? Wenn man jetzt irgendwie, wenn Apple erkennt, das ist ein Song, den es auch bei uns in besserer Qualität gibt, da gebt ihr sogar den in besserer Qualität. Was so ein sicherlich eine Funktionalität ist, die.
Ähm irgendwelchen Urheberrechtsinhaberinnen nicht so äh nicht so gut gefällt und die haben sicherlich Lust, dass äh auch sie eine Liste mit,
nicht zu verwendendem Material pflegen und für die Anbieter verpflichtend machen können. Siehe
Uploadfilter, ja? Wir haben ja genau diese Diskussion gerade, dass also ähm.
Sämtliche Inhalte gescannt werden und ähm in diesem Fall dann die den die Veröffentlichung
Uploadfiltern, also die Veröffentlichung auf der Plattform präventiv sofort verhindert wird. Und ähm nichts anderes als genau eine solche Filtertechnologie, egal wie sie jetzt im Detail anders funktioniert, will Apple jetzt auf die äh
iPhones selber bringen bei den Nutzern in die Geräte, für die sie sehr viel Geld bezahlt haben. Und das sind genau die,
ähm ja, Handlung und Szenarien, vor denen ähm.
Also vor denen immer gewarnt wird, wenn man sich mit closed Software auseinandersetzt, dass nämlich genau äh
in dem Moment, wo sich das Unternehmen entscheidet äh nicht mehr unbedingt in meinem Interesse zu handeln und da eine äh Risikotechnologie in diese Geräte einzubauen, äh die,
dann eben,
mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit eben oder mit mit an Sicherheit grenzender Wahrscheinlichkeiten, Begehrlichkeiten anderer äh Interessengruppen,
wecken, die dann nämlich sagen, die Technologie ist doch da. Ihr könnt jetzt nicht mehr sagen, das ist unmöglich und jetzt möchten wir bitte, dass ihr die auch nutzt. Ähm,
um dann denen du eben nicht mehr entgegentreten können. Und dann hast du genau das Problem, dass du, sage ich jetzt auch, ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass ich einen Nutzer dieser Plattform bin.
Und äh da lange,
jetzt auch ja wie sagt man so schön, investiert bin, also ein verabschieden aus diesem Ökosystem würde mir auf jeden Fall schwerfallen
vor allem natürlich auch in in Ermangelung an brauchbaren Alternativen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ähm.
Dass sich jetzt hier eben ein, ein, ein System, das sich,
viele Jahre relativ zufrieden genutzt habe oder eine Plattform in diesem Gerät, dieses Gerät iPhone ähm,
auf einmal potenziell gegen mich wendet und gegen meine Interessen verstößt und ich denn nichts
machen kann, außer was weiß ich jetzt irgendwie und versuchen, das irgendwie wieder auszubauen, dass Apple nicht meine ähm meine Inhalte scannt. Und ähm.
Wenn ich das an einem Cloud-Anbieter äh missachte, ja,
den kann ich in der Regel einfacher wechseln, noch ja? Oder.
Habe mich nie dazu entschieden, äh ihn zu benutzen, ja oder da war zumindest auch klar, okay, du nutzt eine Cloud
Das sind die Computer von anderen Leuten und die werden sich potenziell äh nicht nicht deinen Interessen,
verpflichtet fühlen. Das ist aber was anderes, wenn ich irgendwie über tausend Euro für ein Telefon ausgebe, dann erwarte ich, dass da eine Software drauf ist, die ausschließlich meinen Interessen gehorcht und diese nicht aufs Spiel setzt. Und jetzt
weiß ich das natürlich für für Hörerinnen und Hörer der Eindruck entsteht, äh dass wir jetzt das das das wir jetzt hier gegen äh Maßnahmen.
Zur Verfolgung oder Erschwerung des Austausches von Sesam ähm.
Argumentieren, darum geht es nicht. Es geht einfach um eine probate Technologie oder eben um eine nicht probate Technologie und das ist keine,
probate Technologie, zumal es nicht dabei bleiben wird, ist, weil es nicht dabei bleiben wird.
Keine einzelne, keine einzelne Technologie dieser Art. Tim, wurde jemals irgendwo eingeführt, ohne dass ihr ähm Anwendungszweck unmittelbar ausgedehnt wurde.
Unmittelbar. Ja, Beispiel, Uploadfilter gegen äh Urheberrechtsverletzungen und jedes andere äh äh System,
der das das ursprünglich mit mit derartigen Materialien,
argumentiert wurde. Ja, Staatstrojaner waren ursprünglich auch nur gegen äh schwere Verbrechen und Terrorismus, ja. Zack, inzwischen werden damit irgendwelche von der Ecke äh angegriffen
Es ist ein ein so sicher wie das Amen in der Kirche.
Ja, also machst es dir jetzt doch ein bisschen einfach, ne? Also ich meine.
Nee, das ist nicht einfach, das ist eine Tatsache, dass äh Grund,
unumstößliche Tatsache, dass wenn solche Systeme gebaut werden, sie anfangs mit schweren Straftaten begründet werden und dass dann im weiteren Verlauf gibt der Sache fünf, gibt der Sache zehn Jahre die Anwendung
ähm ausgeweitet wird. Ein einfaches Beispiel
du wartest gerade in den USA, ja? Wirst du nur, äh da brauchst du auch nicht lange zu warten. In den USA, bis wieder irgendein durchgeknallter Waffennarr ähm auf den Balkon tritt und ein paar Menschen erschießt.
Ja? Und dann hast du zum Beispiel diese Situation.
Ähm die haben wir auch in Deutschland, wenn so etwas passiert. Äh zuletzt war das, glaube ich, in München der Fall, dass dann die Polizei sagt, okay, verbreiten sie nicht diese Materialien oder so
ja? Du hast jetzt gerade die Situation in Afghanistan, wo ähm wahrscheinlich,
auch eine ganze Reihe an ähm sehr, sehr unschönen Bildern, politisch motivierte Tötungen und so,
dokumentiert werden. Das sind auch alles wieder Materialien, äh die die man dann zum Beispiel als Terrorpropaganda und sonstiges bezeichnen kann, wo du selbstverständlich,
als als Staat an Apple herantrittst und sagt, hör mal, ihr habt doch dieses System, mit dem man sicherstellen kann, dass solche
Daten nicht auf den Geräten sind. Ähm nutzt das bitte für diesen Anwendungsfall. Und das ist, du kannst mir doch nicht erzählen, dass diese
ähm dieser Bedarf nicht innerhalb der nächsten fünf Jahre an Apple herangetragen wird.
Ja, aber die Technologie ist auch schon lange auf diesen Geräten.
Das ist doch jetzt gar nix Neues in in der Hinsicht. Also jetzt einzelne Bilder zu finden, ist äh schon immer möglich gewesen. Und wenn jetzt halt,
zu irgendwas gezwungen werden, irgendwas zu tun, dann wäre Ihnen das ja schon immer möglich gewesen.
Argument erschießt sich mir nicht. Also das ist immer möglich gewesen. Es heißt ja nicht, dass es jetzt getan werden muss.
Apple hat ja jetzt nur eine Methode dokumentiert und sehr öffentlich auch dokumentiert.
Wie man so etwas tun kann unter der Maßgabe, dass eben die Privatsphäre dabei trotzdem erhalten wird und sie eben nicht in der Cloud alles durchsuchen.
Das ist ja quasi ihr ihr Pitch an der Stelle. Ja, so nach dem Motto, wir versuchen das eine,
machen, von dem ja, was sie so jetzt quasi für moralisch geboten halten.
Ne, so weil schützen von Menschen ist ja durchaus auch ein Aspekt, den man mal hier äh mit aufbringen muss.
Und versuchen eine Methode dafür zu äh posolieren, die sicherstellt, dass dass die in der Form, wie sie so läuft, wie sie dokumentiert ist, so nicht missbraucht werden kann.
Wie, wieso kann die nicht missbraucht werden?
Na wie würdest du sie denn missbrauchen wollen? Also was.
Habe ich doch gerade formuliert. Also was wäre denn also was ist definiere, Missbrauch und sage wie das unmöglich gemacht wird durch dieses System?
Bin jetzt nicht in der Lage, einhundert Millionen verschiedene äh Angriffsvektoren äh mir auszudenken
ich sehe jetzt erstmal nur, wie diese Technik funktioniert und was sie durch diese Technik versuchen zu verhindern. Ja, sie versuchen zu verhindern, dass sie selber darüber Kenntnis erhalten, wie dieser Vergleich ist. Sie sagen im Übrigen auch in ihrem.
Ähm in ihrem in ihrer Technologie Summery äh Dokumentes, habe ich's nicht komplett durchgelesen, ist ziemlich lang, wo sie eben so verschiedene Angriffsszenarien,
auch ähm.
Beschreiben und wie sie denken, wie ihr System dagegen äh resistent ist, dass unter anderem diese Listen, mit denen sie arbeiten,
von zwei Organisationen kommen müssen, wobei sie jetzt noch nicht gesagt haben, wer denn jetzt bitte die zweite Organisation ist
Ja, also ich spreche jetzt, dass ihr mit dieser NCMEC zusammenarbeiten. Auf der anderen Seite sagen sie aber auch, dass sie quasi die Listen aus zwei Quellen haben wollen und dann nur die Idetyfire benutzen, die eben in beiden Datenbanken drin ist, aber
fehlt mir noch ein bisschen die Information, was diese zweite Organisation ist und ähm jetzt,
müsste man sich halt überlegen, okay, auf welche Art und Weise könnte dieser öffentlich dokumentierte Prozess missbraucht werden? Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo ein Unternehmen,
im Geheimen irgendwas macht.
Indem sie jetzt einfach zu dem nächsten verpflichtet werden.
Ist doch, also zwei Organisationen, die sagen, das sind jetzt hier Terrorinhalte. Es geht ja nicht darum, es geht nicht um einen Ist-Zustand, der ist, es ist ja immer so, dass solche Technologien mit einem
also schleichend eingeführt werden, äh anhand eines Themas, ähm bei dem alle sich einig sind, dass das schon,
hier eine eine sagen wir mal angemessene Abwägung stattfindet, ja? Ähm das ist natürlich naheliegend und auch,
Ich sage natürlich auch, ich habe hier nix zu verbergen, äh ich habe auch keine nennenswerte Befürchtung
hier durch dieses System drangsaliert zu werden. Man redet sich das natürlich klein mit einer unglaublich geringen,
Wahrscheinlichkeit ähm im Betrieb sind irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, über eine Milliarde iPhones auf diesem Planeten, wenn ich das wenn ich mich da nicht täusche, die Leute machen Bilder am laufenden Band.
Egal wie klein die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit ist, sie wird in absolut Unmengen an Zahlen landen äh äh zu zu absolut sehr großen Zahlen führen, egal wie klein die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit ist,
gegen äh wir weiten dieses System auf andere Themenbereiche aus,
ist eben jede technische Implementierung nicht ähm nicht gewachsen. Also da können ja noch so viel schreiben.
Ja gut, sagen wir mal, du bist ein Fotocloud-Anbieter, ja? Du, du bietest jetzt diesen Dienst Leuten an.
Dann ist deine Position, dass sozusagen du keinerlei Verantwortung für die Inhalte hast, die die Leute dort speichern.
Absolut. Und äh ich sollte auch weiterhin keinen Einblick haben in die Inhalte, die die die Leute dort speichern. Und ich kann das auch begründen.
Okay und jetzt sagen wir mal jetzt weiß man dann irgendwann, ja, dass dieser Speicher massenhaft zum speichern von diesem Caesar-Material verwendet wird von Leuten.
Das äh also diese Frage, also ich muss mal ganz ehrlich sagen, so ähm wenn man das weiß, woher weiß man es denn?
Stellt sich doch schon die Frage, dürfte man doch gar nicht wissen.
Ich stelle das übrigens auch in in ich ich ziehe das in Zweifel, dass das der äh dass das äh bei Apple der Fall ist. Also ich kann mir, ich meine, du müsstest schon wirklich
echt mit einem Klammerbeutel gepudert sein, um äh um derartige Materialien in deine Privatcloud zu zu laden. So ähm,
also die Befürchtung, dass das passiert, ja, durchaus klar, kann sein, ähm aber ich kann, ich sehe, sehe keine Zahlen, dass es tatsächlich stattfindet.
Aber wie kann es dann sein, dass Facebook zwanzig Millionen Fälle meldet in einem Jahr.
Da bin ich also das ist also bei Facebook reden wir auch von einer Veröffentlichung, ne? Und jetzt ich äh es gibt auch einen entscheidenden Unterschied von zwischen Facebook und Apple.
Und der, denke ich, ist hier ähm relevant. Wenn du dich in einer Facebook, also die werden ja nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Facebook oder ich habe keine Ahnung von ähm Sesam, ja. Aber die werden ja nicht äh morgens aufstehen und sagen, äh hier, was weiß ich, schönen guten Morgen.
Guck mal hier, schönes Bild. So, das werden wir nicht tun. Die werden im Zweifelsfall irgendwie Facebookgruppen äh oder andere derartige Wohnzimmer, die andere Menschen ihnen bereitstellen, nutzen und machen dort,
Auf jeden Fall irgendeine Art,
der zugänglichmachung. Ja, die, die einzige Weg, etwas, also der einzige Grund, warum etwas bei Facebook landet, ist, dass du es mit mindestens einer weiteren Person teilen möchtest.
Ja, wenn wenn du es für dich hältst, dann bist du bei Facebook falsch. Ja? Und die Foto Library deines privaten,
Smartphones ist deine persönliche Fotolibray. Und zwischen den beiden gibt es einen Unterschied,
und zwar einen fundamentalen. Und wir haben ähm.
Ohnehin, ja, also meine ersten Computer, ja, die waren für mich offline, auch.
Eingeschränkt brauchbar,
ja? Mit denen konnte ich, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Spiele äh spielen, dafür brauchte ich keine Mode im Verbindung oder ich konnte ein Word-Dokument bearbeiten und brauchte äh keine keine Onlineverbindung damit.
Diese ähm diese Tendenz überhaupt,
Personal Computer zu haben, weicht grade massiv auf. Und ähm und zwar durch diese ganze Klauderei und natürlich auch das das äh ja das Nutzungsverhalten,
natürlich interaktiver geworden ist, ne, man irgendwie die ganze Zeit auf
sein Essen fotografieren muss für Instagram und Selfies von sich selber veröffentlichen muss und so. Klar. Aber es gibt eben auch nun mal die private Nutzung und es gibt Dateien, die möchte ich auf meinem Computer speichern und ich muss,
sicher gehen, absolut sicher gehen. Ähm beruflich oder äh journalistisch oder sonst was,
dass diese Datei niemals meinen Computer verlässt. Und ich muss meinen Computer einhundert Prozent vertrauen können, dass der nicht meine Dateien scannt, ja? Äh einer der Gründe
so und heute hast du eine, hast du eine Situation, wo du was weiß ich, irgendwelche Cloud basierten Virenscanner hast, die dir am laufenden Band irgendwelche Dateien zu Virus Toy werfen, ohne mit dir darüber gesprochen zu haben, äh du hast äh deine Foto Library.
Liegt auf anderen Servern und wird dort synchronisiert deinen Apple Notes, deine äh wenn du nicht aufpasst, lädt der deine Passwörter bei denen in die Cloud. Und das, was du zurecht als privaten.
Ähm als privates Gerät auch wahrnimmst, ja ähm erodiert,
zu einer Plattform, wo alle möglichen Daten gesammelt werden. Ja, das ist äh schon dramatischer
heutzutage gebe ich gerne zu, wenn du dich zum Beispiel in in einem Standard-Google-Kontext äh befindest, äh mit einem Android-Telefon, ja? Ähm,
und das ist immer noch.
Eine krasse Veränderung, wenn du dich irgendwie in diesem Apple-Bereich befindest. Du hast ja auch kürzlich werde ich mich nicht täusche, darüber, dich, äh, geärgert, dass die äh HomePots äh ohne Internet überhaupt nicht mehr zu bedienen sind, nicht mehr nutzbar sind.
Ja, okay, aber das ist jetzt, das ist, führt mir jetzt, ehrlich gesagt, ein bisschen in die falsche äh äh Richtung so. Äh abgesehen davon kannst du dieses i-Cloud-Fotos
Dieses Hochladen in deren Cloud abschalten, dann greift diese Methode nicht. So an diese Methode greift nur für die Leute, die ihre Cloud benutzen.
Greift nicht für Leute auf, die auf ihrem Telefon irgendwas speichern.
Und ihre Überprüfungsmethode ist ja auch eine Überprüfungsmethode, die auf dem Telefon überhaupt keinerlei Entscheidungen fällen kann. Sondern es geht
sozusagen nur in der Cloud. Das kannst du tausendmal argumentieren, dass das ja auch alles anders sein kann
Das ist die Methode, die sie jetzt öffentlich dokumentiert haben. Das ist ihre Ansage, das ist das, was wir tun wollen und aus folgenden Gründen ist das irgendwie durch Security-Resserch auch überprüfbar, da kann ich mich nicht zu äußern. Das haben sie jetzt irgendwie da in ihren Dokumenten äh behauptet. Es gibt da irgendwie diverse Papers, die da beiliegen, aber das habe ich jetzt nicht alles durchgelesen und das würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht alles unbedingt verstehen. Ich wollte aufhören
auf was anderes hinaus und das ist eine Perspektive, von der ich finde, dass wir sie auch mal beachten müssen,
weil sie nämlich Teil dieser öffentlichen Debatte ist. Und wenn man in dieser öffentlichen Debatte auch ein Punkt vertreten möchte, wie auch immer dieser Punkt ist,
ja? Muss man den einfach berücksichtigen. Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, was ist, wenn du ein Anbieter bist? Jetzt sage ich mal, was ist, wenn ich ein Anbieter bin,
Ich stelle jetzt diesen Space für die Leute bereit. Und mir kommt es zur Kenntnis, dass der eben dafür verwendet wird.
Habe ich damit ein Problem.
Ist das für mich moralisches Problem, ist vielleicht kein legales Problem. Vielleicht gibt's diese Gesetze nicht und so weiter, aber habe ich als Anbieter ein Problem damit?
Ist das für mich sozusagen wichtiger, dogmatisch zu sagen, mit.
Ja nee, äh mir doch egal, was ihr macht. Ja, oder äh dringt in mein Gewissen, äh die Erkenntnis rein.
Das, was ich jetzt hier mache und womit ich Geld verdiene, trägt auch dazu bei, dem Treiben,
Vorschub zu leisten, weil ich denen eine Dienstleistung anbiete. Und wir haben oft solche Diskussionen,
Bitcoin, was das irgendwie trägt und so weiter. Kann man irgendwie Kryptosysteme, die völlig anonym sind, ist das sozusagen moralisch haltbar. Ja, legal mag das alles sein, aber ist das, ist das moralisch vertretbar, dass man das äh sozusagen gegen
alle politischen Versuche, das zu regulieren verteidigt,
Wenn man gleichzeitig weiß, was dadurch auch ermöglicht wird, das sind abwägen. Und in dem Fall und ich sage dir das auch ganz ehrlich.
Mia, wer das nicht egal. Mir wäre das nicht egal und jetzt muss ich quasi ein, ein Weg finden,
wie ich das, wie ich das balanciert bekomme. Und die eine Möglichkeit wäre, ich stelle den Dienst ein.
Ja, das wäre definitiv die eine Methode und es gibt einiges in meinem Leben, was ich nicht tue oder weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass das für die Gesellschaft in irgendeiner Form,
schädlich wäre. Deswegen tue ich diese Dinge nicht. Ich weiß, dass andere Leute die Dinge tun, die müssen das irgendwie mit mit ihrem eigenen Herzen und Kopf äh für sich bewerten, aber ich tue sie deshalb halt nicht. Und in dem Fall wäre das natürlich eine Fragestellung,
ich mir auch stellen muss. Und das gilt sicherlich nicht nur für das Thema, aber es gilt auch für dieses Thema.
So und das ist glaube ich auch die Fragestellung, die sich Apple stellt an der Stelle. Das nehme ich ihnen einfach an der Stelle aber auch wirklich mal ab,
Ja, weil ihre Geräte sind halt in der Hand von vielen Kindern. Ihre Geräte sind eben ein Kommunikationsbeschleuniger. Und so viel Gutes das tut und so viel äh Privates das schützt und so weiter, wissen sie auch,
dass eben Missbrauch auch stattfindet. Und die Frage, die sie sich gestellt haben. Und das ist jetzt quasi die Antwort, die sie darauf gegeben haben, ist, gibt es dort etwas, was wir tun können,
um unser moralischen Verpflichtung und teilweise eben auch unserer legalen Verpflichtung, damit äh auch äh gerecht zu werden.
Und jetzt haben sie halt ein.
Einen technischen Weg gesucht und meinen, den jetzt gefunden zu haben, der in dieses moralische Handeln ermöglicht,
Mit der Behauptung, dabei eben die anderen Sachen, die ihnen genauso zu wichtig sein scheinen, wie Privatsphäre, nicht zu verletzen.
Wenn du.
Diesen Cloud-Service anbietest, Tim, ne? Den, den du ja jetzt äh für dich annimmst, dann wirst du dann tatsächlich machst, ist, du vermietest Festplattenplatz,
ja? Du hast ähm Server mit Festplatten drin,
vielleicht sogar mit einer kleinen SSD oder so. Und ähm du hast ein Geschäftsmodell daraus entwickelt, eine gewisse Menge Speicherplatz auf diesen Servern, deinen Kundinnen und Kunden für einen bestimmten monatlichen Beitrag,
zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das ist das, was Cloud bedeutet. Ja? Und.
Wenn du argumentierst, dass du dass dass dann für dich ein Problem ist, welche Bits die Menschen auf diesen ähm Festplatten speichern, dann kann ich das äh kann ich durchaus verstehen, ja, dass man solche, dass man.
Einen solchen Service vielleicht ungerne.
Anbietet, ja? Aber du gehst jetzt auch davon aus, als wäre das hier die hauptsächliche Nutzung. Und das ist ja äh mit mit Sicherheit nicht der Fall.
Nein, das habe ich damit nicht gesagt. Das ist die hauptsächlich ist.
Ganz kurz, bei den Festplattenthemen zu bleiben. Ähm ich muss weil hier wieder so ein scheiß Festplatte kaputt ist. Ich muss jetzt mir wieder neue holen oder wenn ich Glück habe, kriege ich die noch äh kriege ich die noch ersetzt von äh Western Digital, weil die,
in der Regel ja nach einem Jahr
gehen, aber zwei Jahre Garantie haben. Äh das heißt, einmal kann man die kostenlos austauschen. Muss jetzt wahrscheinlich bald wieder Festplatten kaufen. Und da sagt Western Digital auch nicht, das darfst du darauf speichern und das nicht.
Ja äh mir sagt auch Heckler und kocht nicht, dass ich mit ihrem Maschinengewehr äh äh nur Bösewichte erschießen äh darf. Verstehst du? Das ist genau dasselbe.
Doch und da ist jetzt genau, da ist aber der entscheidende Unterschied. Wenn du, wenn du äh Festplatten herstellst, dann kannst du.
Sehr gut in dem Wissen schlafen, dass deine Festplatten größtenteils relativ harmlose Bits und Beids speichern.
Und zwar in sehr überwiegendem Ausmaß. Wenn du Heckler und Koch bist.
Dann kannst du dich eventuell noch damit trösten, dass deine Waffen.
In in einem gewissen Prozentsatz äh der Fälle ähm ihr Ziel verfehlen und deshalb nicht ganz so viele Leute töten. Die sind aber fürs Töten gemacht worden.
Und ähm dann.
Kannst du vielleicht auch sagen, okay, wir haben eine moralische äh Verpflichtung, der wir nicht gerecht werden, weil wir nun mal äh tödliche Waffen in die Welt setzen. Das ist, ne? Und das kann auch dich zum Beispiel dazu führen, bestimmte Services,
zu unterstützen oder nicht, ja? Zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, das Tornetzwerk.
Kann sein, dass du das Tor finde ich irgendwie total geil, ich möchte ich ich investiere in Server um Exit-Notes oder Middle-Notes oder sonst was zu betreiben oder du kannst irgendwann zu dem Eindruck gelangen, dass dass das ein System ist,
zu dem du nicht mehr beitragen möchtest. So, das äh sind jetzt so,
da würde ich deine Argumentation so werten. Aber wenn du ein Fotocloud hast, wo wo der größte, der größte Teil der Inhalte wahrscheinlich Selfies, Mittagessen und irgendwelche Fotos von von niedlichen Tieren sind.
Und sagst, okay, es gibt einen winzigen Prozentsatz der Menschheit, die potenziell darin Inhalte haben, die mir nicht gefallen, ja.
Dann aber auch nur spezifische Inhalte, die mir nicht gefallen, weil es ja relativ viele Inhalte gibt, die mir vielleicht persönlich nicht gefallen. Wahrscheinlich gefallen mir die meisten Foto Librarys nicht die Leute haben. Ähm,
dann zu sagen, ja okay, die äh darfst du aber nicht haben. Das finde ich übrigens nicht klar genug gemacht bei diesen Cloud-Anbietern genauso ähm,
inakzeptabel. Die sagen dir aber nicht, äh oder die täuschen dir nicht vor, sie wären an deiner Privatsphäre interessiert. Und ich sehe das wirklich ähm.
Nicht so.
Nicht so gut, was die da machen, weil ich auch wirklich da dahin gehe und das wird, wird vielleicht vielen Leuten nicht gefallen. Das,
ich davon ausgehe, dass das wirklich halt im Promillebereich äh oder oder weit weiter runter noch befindet, die Nutzerinnen, die die vielleicht derartige Materialien auf ihr iPhone laden.
Und ähm dass das eben die die die ähm in einem Bereich ist, dass der nicht.
Diesen schwerwiegenden Eingriff. Wir bauen jetzt einen Scanner in deine Hardware ein und du kannst den da nicht rauskriegen und wir prüfen deine Bilder und du kannst deinem dein dein Gerät arbeitet potenziell gegen dich im Fehlerfall.
Wann, ab wie viel Prozent ändert sich dein moralischer Kompass an der Stelle, also fünf Prozent, zehn Prozent, zwanzig Prozent.
Ja ich würde wahrscheinlich irgendwo in diesem Bereich gehen, ja.
Okay, also ein Prozent ist okay.
Mir fünf, also.
Von Milliarden, an.
Unter fünf Prozent als das äh ähm als das äh ähm seltene Ereignis definiert. Und wir reden hier von Bruchteilen davon,
Aber wir reden davon, dass diese diese Scanner auf äh ja Milliardentelefone kommen.
Und eben das äh Missbrauchspotential durch andere juristische Anforderungen haben. Du hast da, weißt du, du sagst jetzt hier, okay, das gilt nur in den USA
der wird ja jetzt sicherlich nicht China sagen übrigens Apple. Wir haben gesehen, ihr habt da was Schönes. Äh wir haben uns überlegt, folgende Inhalte könnt ihr mal für uns löschen.
So, das wird ja bestimmt nicht passieren, dass ja sonst auch nie passiert. Also solche Technologien baut man halt nicht, ja? Das ist der der gleiche Grund, warum du bestimmte Technologien nicht baust, die eben vielleicht sehr gut dafür geeignet sind,
hier zu verteilen, ne? Dann entscheidet man sich, okay, so etwas baue ich nicht, weil ich eine Technologie baue, die massiver ähm.
Massiven Missbrauch.
Vorschub leistet und fast dafür gebaut wurde, nur missbräuchige Nutzung anzuziehen. Und das ist ja jetzt eine iCloud-Foto Library eben nicht.
Naja, es du sagst jetzt im Prinzip so eine Millionen Leute, die das machen, ist okay.
Nein, das sage ich nicht, Tim, so soll das auch jetzt einfach unlautern, das sieht man auch sehr genau nachfühlen. Ich habe gesagt, ist ein
ähm im Promillebereich befindet sich das und das ist äh es äh sind also sehr, sehr wenige Menschen, die das tun. Und ähm wenn das äh ähm.
Die,
Die Maßnahme betrifft immer die Grundgesamtheit, ja? Und du kannst natürlich sagen, äh der Linus toleriert eine Million Menschen, die so etwas tun. Nein, der Linus will eine Milliarde Menschen, die das nicht tun, davor bewahren, dass ihre Hintertür bekommen.
Na ja, jetzt ist halt die Frage, was ist eine äh Hintertür, eine Hintertür ist etwas, wo jeder äh unkontrolliert reingehen kann? Und das ist es ja an dieser Stelle nicht.
Na ja, ich habe ja schon jetzt mehrmals versucht zu erklären, dass es eben eine ein sich beugen nach juristischen Anforderungen ist
äh ein ähm letztendlich äh Schwächen ähm von Verschlüsselungsmethoden, eine Verletzung der des Privatsphäreversprechens
und es ist, denke ich, unstrittig, dass,
andere Kulturbereiche mit anderen mit anderen Vorstellungen davon, was du auf deinem Gerät haben sollst oder nicht. Äh diese Technologie ebenfalls für sich beanspruchen.
Werden.
Ja, also Verschlüsselungsmethoden werden ja hier nicht geschwächt. Das ist ja schon mal ein interessanter Eigenschaft davon, muss man jetzt
äh auch mal so sehen. Und tatsächlich könnte das sogar auch eine Methode sein, die es Apple wiederum ermöglicht, diese ganze ICloud-Speicherei eben sogar noch sehr viel besser zu verschlüsseln, weil sie dann trotzdem ihren Anforderungen noch gerecht werden können.
Dadurch, dass sie quasi diesen Scheck kryptografisch auf den Zeitpunkt des Uploads, ja
verlagern, können sie alles andere verschlüsseln, ohne sich dort ähm zwingen zu lassen, dafür eine Vektor anzubieten
Man kann es also auch genauso gut so sehen, dass es unter Umständen ein Pfad ist, der explizit das Einrichten von Pektors auch verhindern kann.
Weil er eine Vektor ist, dass er mit der gleichen Argumentation äh also wir diskutieren in in zwei Folgen vorher darüber, dass die EU ähm äh EU
EU mit dieser Chatkontroll Initiative in die deine Chat scannen möchte in in verschlüsselten Messengern und das nicht darf, ja? Also solche Technologien,
bieten wir aus gutem Grund. Ja, das ist verboten. Deswegen,
weichen sie ja die E-Privacy-Detektive auf, um das zu tun. Also sie verletzen äh und es ist exakt das Gleiche, ja. Sie verletzten ähm es trifft ja hier auch auf Messages zu. Sie verletzen äh dann äh,
damit quasi Gesetze, von denen sie vorher eigentlich relativ sicher waren, dass die gut sind. Und neben der, nehmen uns damit Rechte und Schutzrechte weg,
Ja, das ist und es ist die gleiche Technologie, also das, was unter Chatkontrolle äh diskutiert wird, ist ähm,
vielleicht in in technischen Details ähm,
noch unterscheidbar von dem was Apple jetzt hier sehr genau schon mal formuliert hat, aber es ist von der von der gesellschaftlichen Wirkung, von der Initiative her genau das Gleiche. Und auch da werden.
Weiß ich nicht, wie viele Milliarden blöde Nachrichten versendet jeden Tag, ja? Und die werden alle von diesem Scanner untersucht werden.
Und da findest du das, glaube ich, auch nicht in Ordnung.
Das ist ja auch noch eine andere Sache. Die Frage ist ja immer, wem gibst du Zugang? Also wer hat sozusagen Zugang zu diesem System? Ja, also wer hat überhaupt Zugang zum Handling dieser Nachrichten? Und gibt es eine Möglichkeit
Das ist ja die die Frage. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, ein eine moralische Verantwortung, die man gegenüber der Gesellschaft auch hat
in irgendeiner Form so zu implementieren, um das andere nicht in Gefahr zu bringen,
Das ist ja die Frage, die jetzt an dieser Stelle im Raum steht. Du bist jetzt auf der stringenten Grundmeinung mit nichts darf da jemals getan werden. Du sollst das alles in Gefahr,
Kann ich auch verstehen, weil so wie es halt meistens auch gehandhabt wird, bringt es eben die Sachen auch in Gefahr. Ich sage nur.
Ich denke, es ist wertvoll, die die angezeigt,
Lösungen auch separat zu analysieren, weil sie halt unter Umständen gerade auch einen Weg aus dieser Falle heraus zeigen können. Dass man sagen kann.
Hör mal, ich weiß, ihr habt da irgendwie jetzt den Druck hier alles aufzumachen und ihr wollt die die dicken Backdoors einbauen, ja? Aber,
Wir können euch auch unter Verwendung von kryptographischen Systemen einen Weg zeigen, wie äh das alles nicht erforderlich ist und trotzdem wird das, von dem ihr immer behauptet, was ihr tun wollt.
Und nur das wird realisiert und damit nimmt man ihnen natürlich auch das Argument,
Raus, weil gerade dieses Problem, das halt über
Material, Zugriff erlangt werden soll auf alles andere, ja? Da ist es ja eigentlich ein ganz eleganter Gedanke zu sagen,
Ist alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Gucke mal, wir haben hier eine Privatsphäre schon äh Methode herausgefunden, wie man das ganz gezielt rauslösen kann und nur genau das,
ja? Und deswegen braucht ihr alles andere nicht zu machen. Das mal.
In den Raum gestellt. Wir müssen diese Debatte jetzt nicht abschließen und, und, und, und äh auf einen Punkt bringen, sondern ich würde gerne diesen Gedankenraum an der Stelle auch äh offen lassen können.
Okay, ähm Apple-Mitarbeiter äh wenden sich auch dagegen. Wer möchte, kann sich noch ein paar Sachen.
Angucken, aber es gibt einfach manchmal Dinge, die sollte man lieber nicht bauen, egal wie schön und elegant man sie baut, ja? Das äh, denke ich, sollte man,
so erkennen und das haben wir zum Beispiel auch gesagt bei der Luca App, ja, wo klar war, dass es ein zentrales System und das ist keine gute Idee
äh und die kann man auch nicht gut machen, dadurch, dass man halbherzig noch irgendeine Verschlüsselung dran kloppt, kloppelt.
Und jetzt langsam so, langsam, langsam, langsam häufen sich dann jetzt auch die Berichte.
Und darüber, dass die tolle Luca-App, von der immer gesagt wird, die funktioniert, äh, nicht funktioniert, ja, in Bad Doberan gab es eine,
Party mit ursprünglich zwei Corona Infizierten. Inzwischen sind dort äh elf positive Fälle und die kommen nicht an die Luca-Daten. Ist nicht der erste Fall. Ich hatte das auch hier in der Sendung sofort gesagt
dass eben sagt, okay, wir verschlüsseln, die Leute müssen dann auf diesen Schlüssel aufpassen und dass die ähm.
Anbieter quasi, also die die Locations. Die sind Schlüssel eben sicher verwahren müssen. Und ein Schlüssel sicher zu verwahren ist ein,
Ist ein Problem, das wir alle kennen, ja? Es gibt kaum eine Person, die nur einen PGP hat,
weil alle beim ersten Mal einen generieren und den verlieren, ja? Also jede PGP-Nutzerin oder eine größere Teil der PGP-Nutzerin hat zwei Schlüssel, weil sie den ersten irgendwann mal verloren hat
und dann gelernt hat, ach so, Scheiße, wenn man den wenn man den verloren hat, äh kann man gar nicht äh mehr entschlüsseln. Da hätte ich ja vorher wissen müssen, steht da auch Groß und Rot?
Ja, insofern ist das ein ein klares Problem, dass wenn man heutzutage mit Leuten eine Verschlüsselungstechnologie anbietet, dass man sich sehr viel Mühe geben muss,
sie dahin zu natschen auch wirklich die Schlüssel sicher zu verwahren. Machen zum Beispiel auch so einen Messenger wie Signal, äh dass sie äh versuchen
dich zu einem Schlüssel-Backup zu äh zu bringen oder dass sie dir halt irgendwie eine PIN aufschwatzen und dich äh dich dann regelmäßig an die PIN erinnern, damit du die nicht verlierst oder sonstiges. All diese äh dieses Wissen hat
äh darauf verzichtet, Luca und äh Daniel ist noch viel besser.
Jetzt ist es also so, dass diese Betreiberin von dieser Diskothek da nicht an den Schlüssel kommt, ist auch nicht der einzige Fall.
Dann geb die sogar noch den Location-Betreibern daran die Schuld. Ja, also die sind sich noch nicht mal zu fein, die dann eben auch äh,
ähm denen den Fehler zu unterstellen. Jetzt ist es in diesem Fall sogar so, dass der Anbieter hier dementiert den äh Schlüssel verloren zu haben. In ähm.
Im bayrischen Rundfunk äh wird viel darüber berichtet, dass es hier keine äh keine vernünftige,
Sommers Anbindung gibt, dass zu viele Daten gesammelt werden, also zu viele Daten da rausfallen, also diese Datensammlung als solche keinen Sinn macht, alles Dinge.
Die wir schon besprochen haben und es gibt eine sogar vom Spiegel jetzt im im Printspiegel eine,
Story, wo viele Gesundheitsämter gefragt werden und,
die Mehrheit der Gesundheitsämter, für die das ja sein soll, ja, die Gesundheitsämter, für die das sein soll, halten die für wertlos und nutzen sie nicht, ja? Es ist nicht ersichtlich, was der Einsatz der Luca-App,
bringen würde oder hier äh ein Arzt im Gesundheitsamt Nordrhein-Westfalen äh in der in in Remscheid, in Nordrhein-Westfalen sagt, bisher,
kein einziger infizierter gegenüber dem Amt angegeben, die Luca-App benutzt zu haben. Wir fragen alle Personen, die normale Corona-Warn-App ist, immer mal wieder dabei,
andere Apps so gut wie nie. Aber sagt er, ist nicht schlimm
Denn das würde die Arbeit ohnehin nicht erleichtern, im Gegenteil. Nimmt man einfach mal an, dass wir nach einem Festival mit zwanzigtausend Besuchern alle eingebuchten Besucher abarbeiten müssten, wäre das ohnehin ein Ding der Ohnmachtbarkeit. Festivals mit zwanzigtausend Personen,
Nordrhein-Westfalen da veranstaltet. Große Dimensionen, aber ne, das ist halt äh bei einem Festival ist es so, aber das ist auch schon bei einem einfachen Restaurant so, weil du eben nicht alle.
Ansteckst. Also hier von Patrick Beuth, Max Hoppenstedt und mehreren anderen Autoren auch nochmal ein Spiegelartikel, online ist er nur,
mit Spiegel plus lesbar. Das heißt so langsam, langsam, langsam, merken jetzt alle, äh welchen.
Welchem Geschäftsmodell sie hier.
Aufgesessen sind. Gleichzeitig ähm lesen sich dann so die die Antworten von den Gesundheitsämtern, die irgendwie pro Luca sind. Die lesen sich echt immer so wie eine Werbebroschüre von Nexenio. Und äh ich glaube, als einziges Land ist da so,
Baden-Württemberg noch immer begeistert. Die werden ja nicht müde. Äh auch eigene Promotion. Promotion-Materialien für Nexinio, Luca zu formulieren und äh aber so wirklich die Erfolgsgeschichten bleiben aus und das haben wir ja auch,
so
Vorhergesagt.
Ähm vorhergesagt. Habe ich heute auch einen äh Journalisten gesagt, der mich danach nochmal gefragt hat.
Und dann gab es jetzt die erste äh DSGVO Strafe für
Ich vermute, dass es die erste ist ähm für veraltete Software. Da hat ein Unternehmen, das ist auch wirklich ähm bärenstark. Ähm ein ein äh Unternehmen ähm.
Webshop betrieben und zwar ähm,
XT-Commerce drei Punkt null vier SP zwei Punkt eins und diese Version ist seit zwanzig vierzehn veraltet und wird nicht mehr mit Sicherheits-Update mit Sicherheits-Updates versorgt. Also zweitausendvierzehn, ja, veraltet.
Sie und der äh Hersteller warnt ausdrücklich davor, die noch weiter einzusetzen, weil sie erhebliche Sicherheitslücken hat, darunter unter anderem eine SQL Injection, also ein.
Angriff, wo man die Datenbanken direkt auslesen kann. Und die niedersächsische,
Datenschutzbehörde hat äh ähm recherchiert und ergeben äh herausgefunden, dass die Passwörter dort nur MD fünf,
waren, also ein ähm Verfahren, das äh glaube ich als Funktion ohnehin jetzt langsam mal ausgedient hat und ähm.
Eben offenbar auch nicht waren. Also für.
Einfache Angriff von MD fünf,
einfach so im Internet gibt, sehr anfällig, ja? Und äh genau ohne Salt, das ist also wirklich hier ein Verstoß gegen äh etablierte Richtlinien und äh Herstellerempfehlungen und
dann haben sie äh,
dafür eine hat das Unternehmen dafür eine Strafe bekommen und zwar fünfundsechzigtausendfünfhundert Euro und das Unternehmen hat äh Klug beraten, diese Strafe auch,
akzeptiert.
Das will man ja wohl mal meinen, dass sie das akzeptiert, weil sie sich dagegen zu wehren, dürfte etwas schwierig sein.
Zugunsten der Firma wurde dabei berücksichtigt, dass diese schon vor dem Bußgeldverfahren den betroffenen Personen äh einen Passwortwechsel nahegelegt.
Wie nett.
Schadensmildernde Umstände. Ja.
Ja, natürlich hat er ihn ins Bein geschossen, aber er hat auch Entschuldigung gesagt.
Ich habe ich habe vor Jahren auch mal so einen XT-Commerce äh.
Und das waren, also seitdem ich das Ding nicht mehr an der Backe habe, schlafe ich auf jeden Fall um einiges ruhiger. Das kann ich dir sagen. Das willst du nicht.
Bin jetzt mal, ich frage mich ernsthaft wie also wie der Server überhaupt so lange angeblieben ist, ja, dass denn dass der nicht schon längst irgendwie in in äh strenger äh in strenger anderer Hand war, also das war sicherlich irgendwie.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass da nur ein Angreifer auf so einem Server hängt, vor allem weil diese ähm diese Art Angriffe natürlich, also wenn die so alt sind,
ähm in jedem automatisierten Scanner sind und einfach von Internet Grundrauschen äh dein dein Hacker äh dein dein Server dann halt gehackt wird. Kann ich gar nicht verstehen, wie der so lange noch an war, ja, dass denn nicht längst irgendjemand
ja, keine Ahnung. Wobei, na ja, anlassen, den die Angreifer ja auch.
Ist die Frage, was äh was was da so verkauft wurde, also.
Also ich kann mir.
Ehrlich gesagt, kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass du, dass dieser Shop noch im Betrieb war. Ich gehe davon aus, dass dir den einfach dass das eine eine Karteileiche war. Kannst mir nicht anders erklären.
Aber da hätten sie ja die User äh nicht benachrichtigen müssen, um ihre Passwörter zu ändern, wenn wenn sie gleich abschalten.
Nur weil das sieben Jahre alte User sind, heißt ja nicht, dass du nicht trotzdem deren Daten nicht gesichert hast.
Also nee, also wirklich, die die Leute, die die lassen so was einfach ewig, so lange es nicht komplett äh, wenn es nicht von alleine auseinanderfällt.
Ja, dann, dann, dann lasst es, ja, das läuft doch noch. Gucke mal hier, die Farben sind auch immer noch immer noch die gleichen. Ist nicht schlecht geworden.
Kein Schimmel, ja. Das Rot ist noch knallig, wird nicht blass.
Okay.
Jo, so sieht's aus in der Welt des Internets.
Ja und das heißt, das war's äh dann von uns diese Woche. Nächste Woche vielleicht gibt's dann schon den nächsten Statuscode. Mhm.
Der, weiß ich gar nicht genau, wer hier das ist, hier sitze ich gerade nicht auf Anhieb gefunden.
Kann ich dir sagen. Hast nicht gefunden.
Habe ich nicht auf das jetzt nicht gefunden.
Ah, ich schaue nachher nochmal, ob ich den finde.
Können wir noch mal gucken. Ne, ist ja ein Vierer. Könnte ja sein, dass der sich nach einer Zeit wieder äh.
Von alleine.
In Wohlgefallen auflöst.
Wie alle anderen Probleme, die wir besprochen haben auch. Kann sein, dass sie sich alle einen Wohlgefallen auflösen.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Unwahrscheinlich. Aber nur weil Sachen unwahrscheinlich sind, soll man doch seinen Glauben daran nicht verlieren, oder? Sonst kann man's auch gleich sein lassen.
So denn wir wünschen euch einen einen schönen äh Abend.
Oder Tag oder morgen.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.